again you know next year
you've got guardians of the galaxy vol 2
coming and that whole concept started
from you all saying when are you gonna
be in a Marvel movie when are you gonna
be in a Marvel movie and you remember
the first picture after that Marvel
meeting that I had where I was standing
in the Avengers big what's in the
background some of you could look it up
you know that picture where that there
was an Avengers old like a 67 hour on
old Avengers copy that was behind me in
that picture if you look back on my
Facebook page you can find that what's
gonna be surreal as that picture is
going to come to pass because now the
guardians will be included in Avengers
affinity Wars and that's incredibly
exciting incredibly excited incredibly
exciting and something that if you are
part of our page you knew before
everybody or you were told before
everybody
hey youtubers is Charlie so many marvel
bombs dropping guardians Avengers
crossover so there's just gonna be a
breakdown of what's going on and what
the crossover point I think is going to
be so the prophecy comes true this is
actually the picture that he was talking
about the Avengers picture that he was
standing in front of way way before he
ever did the voice for Groot I like the
element of prophecy like everybody
started talking about something then it
became a thing he talks about his other
movies the same way too if you're
wondering what this is all about
Facebook sent him an award for getting
over a hundred million likes on his
Facebook page he has like one of the
biggest Facebook pages in the entire
world so he was kind of like crying and
fangirling on all the people that he got
to work with how happy is just saying
thank you to all the fans just being
very gracious to everyone but you know
this he just manages to drop this and I
like the way he talks about it too if
you're part of the famine you found this
out before everyone else so it's funny
how now big things like this get found
out in offhanded Facebook post I don't
know if he did this intentionally or if
he had arranged behind the scenes to
announce this but either way it's out
there and you know it makes sense we
already knew that Peter quill was going
to be in Avengers infinity war but we
didn't know if the other Guardians would
be but since we're talking about Vin
Diesel here a lot of you are probably
wondering is baby Groot going to be in
Avengers infinity war or will he be
fully grown again and I think the answer
is in all the merchandising so don't you
think it would be funnier on screen
especially for younger viewers who
really identify with the baby Groot
character if they were to have a lot of
scenes with baby Groot in the other
Avengers like Tony Stark reacting to
baby Groot so I think they're just gonna
have a lot of fun with that idea so I am
expecting baby Groot in the crossover
it's just easier for them to merchandise
baby Groot too you have to remember it's
a Disney movie they're thinking about
the youth audience little kids love baby
Groot toys they might make a billion
dollars on the movie but they'll make
like two or three billion dollars on all
the baby Groot toys that they sell so a
couple other big things the Russos have
said you know a lot of people are
wondering what the title for the fourth
Avengers film is gonna be because it's
not infinity War part 2 anymore I still
think that it's going to be like all-new
all-different Avengers whatever the
title ends up being it's just gonna mark
the beginning of the New Avengers team
whatever that
like like spider-man is a good example
of one of the New Avengers characters he
will be a part of the Avengers going
forward we'll have Captain Marvel will
have Doctor Strange
they'll just be other characters that
they'll slowly be weaving in like
they'll be more black panther in the
avengers movies the Russo said that
they're not going to reveal the title
for Avengers 4 for a long time just
because it sounds like it'd be spoilery
like it'd be called new Avengers and
that would let you know that the
Avengers are going away so even though
you're reading all the clues and you
probably know this like they just they
want to keep it as non spoilery as
possible but they said that the 3rd
Avengers film Avengers infinity war will
be the culmination of all the stuff that
they've been doing so far Avengers 4
will be a new beginning which is why I'm
just thinking all-new all-different
Avengers so while it's kind of up in the
air I do think that some of the older
Avengers will still stick around Robert
Downey jr. has already said that he's in
it for the long haul so we will have
like the Papa Tony Stark lording over
all these new avengers kids like imagine
a version of The Breakfast Club where
all the new Avengers are stuck in
detention Tony Stark taking on more of a
parental role even though he'll always
have really badass armor he'll have all
kinds of new toys but really like the
action is in introducing the new
characters like look at all this awesome
stuff that spider-man is doing get to
know Black Panther better learn about
magic through Doctor Strange Tony Stark
will probably become more of a support
character I mean he's just one example
but I think that he's gonna be around
for the long haul Captain America I
think that Chris Evans is going to leave
maybe they'll pass the mantle of Captain
America to another character maybe
they'll just retire the title for a
little while before reintroducing it but
going into phase 4 the Avengers will
look very different from what they look
like today
but because guardians of the galaxy 2 is
coming up I know a lot of you are
wondering if we're gonna see moments of
crossover with the other movies James
Gunn said that's pretty much not going
to happen
no Thanos no infinity gem he just wrote
it as like a self-contained really
cosmic awesome story and he said that he
might not be doing a third guardians
film so however the guardians are going
to be crossing over with the Avengers an
infinity war that will all happen during
infinity war we might see shades of that
in a post-credits scene but let me know
in the
what do you think the event is going to
be that causes the Guardians to go back
to earth like maybe Thor and Hulk will
encounter some Guardians story elements
on their road trip during thor ragnarok
so that would be a logical story
crossover point for the Guardians stuff
even if you don't see guardians in Thor
Ragnarok but right now the Thor movies
are kind of like the halfway point
between the guardians movies in the
earth-based Avengers movies because Thor
is in space but he's largely an
earth-based Avenger character er he has
been so far so don't be surprised if you
see some guardians related stuff
happening during Thor Ragnarok that goes
beyond Thanos infinity gem that that'll
be happening too but I feel like
there'll be some other stuff to link
guardians to the main Avengers films but
let me know what do you think that's
going to be I feel like an easy
crossover point would be the collector
because he's one of the elders of the
universe the Grandmaster is gonna be in
Thor played by Jeff Goldblum's character
so those two characters both being
elders of the universe would probably be
aware of each other if the Kree got
involved with the Asgardians and a big
conflict that'd be another crossover
point but there's a number of different
ways they could choose for it to go down
and let me know what do you think is
gonna happen if they don't do a third
guardians film James Gunn is like I
wrote guardians to is this really nice
self-contained story I have an idea for
guardians 3 but I don't know if I'm
gonna do it so if you really do want him
to make a third guardians film and I
certainly do make sure to make some
noise about it but I'm sure he
understands that the fans definitely
want more guardians films I feel like at
this point it's really just a question
of him finding his story that he's
really interested in doing so get height
and there is a new round of the giveaway
all you guys have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video if you guys haven't seen it I just
did a big spider-man homecoming video
they just dropped a mary jane bomb so a
whole bunch of Marvel movie news
happening right now where you guys wait
for my next video you can click here to
learn all about mary jane and spider-man
homecoming and you can click here for my
breakdown of the guardians of the galaxy
to comic-con trailer thank you so much
for watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight